I think we know enough about shorting
now that we can start thinking about
whether it's a good or bad thing to have
in financial markets what I've done here
is I've drawn a hypothetical stock chart
for a company this is time right here
this is the price of the company and
let's just say that this is a chart in a
universe that doesn't have short sellers
in it so this is all you know here a lot
of people are buying the stock then over
here some people maybe they get freaked
out or whatever they start selling and
then more people buy so you know demands
a little higher than some then supply so
there's you know the price goes up and
you know you that that just generally
drives the volatility now in a short
selling world what would happen let me
let's think about two scenarios a short
seller who makes money and a short
seller who loses money so a short seller
making money what a short seller making
money have to do if this is the stock
trade obviously they don't see the stock
chart beyond the day that they're
actually making the trade but in order
to make money they'll actually they'll
have to short at the the local peaks and
they would have to cover their shorts at
the local minimum so good shorts are or
you could even say a perfect short
seller would maybe short here let me
make it a different color so you can see
where he's acting would short here and
then cover there right and you'd make
that that much money on that move and
then he would wait a little bit wait for
the stock to get expensive again in his
mind and he was short here and then he
would cover here this would kind of be
obviously it's very unlikely that
someone could be so well picked tops and
bottoms but let's say they're just
really good at their analysis and
figuring out market psychology and
things like that and they would just
keep doing it they was short here and
cover here what would that actually do
to the stock right the Green Line was a
reality where you had no short sellers
now if you all of a sudden you allowed
short selling and they had these guys
coming to the market who know how to
make money shorting he's shorting up
here so what was shorting do shorting is
you're borrowing the stock and selling
it so he's creating extra supply for the
stock right so what he would be doing at
this point by shorting is he would
actually be lowering the price at this
point so let me draw the curve
so there's a bunch of short sellers
acting in this range it would actually
lower the peak because you have a bunch
you have some more aggregate sellers
right so the price wouldn't go as high
and then on the other hand these short
sellers have to cover right here right
they're going to cover their position so
at the low point you have more aggregate
buyers covering a short position is just
you're buying the stock to pay it back
because you borrowed it earlier so here
you would have more aggregate buyers and
then at this point once again you have
more aggregate sellers so the price
won't go as high you have more aggregate
buyers here because the short sellers
need to cover so the price won't go as
low and so forth and so on and the
bottom line is a short seller a short
seller who is making money on the stock
market so they're shorting the stock at
Peaks and covering the stock at troughs
is actually reducing the volatility of
the stock and that's good for everybody
that's good for the company's management
that's good for the actual shareholders
of the company and obviously it's good
for the short sellers because they are
they're actually making money and this
is actually true for anyone making money
in the stock market that they're
reducing volatility what is a long just
a regular investor I guess you could
call them a trader since they're buying
and selling a regular trader would make
money by buying here and selling here
buying here and selling here so really a
regular trader is doing is not any
different a regular long trader is no
different than a short seller it's just
the order in which they're buying or
selling
but anyone making money is buying at low
points and selling at high points and
anyone doing that is helping to reduce
the volatility in the stock and even if
you're a long term buy and hold player
you would rather sit and hold a stock
with my computers doing weird things you
would rather be a holder of a stock that
does this then a holder of a stock that
does that does this now there are a lot
of players both on you know you call
them traders because they're buying and
selling on a regular basis that aren't
kind of doing this right
maybe there's there they're putting
their piling on the shorts at a low
point and they're causing the stock to
go down even more and then when the
stock starts to move up they get scared
and they buy it and then it causes the
stock to move up even more and it
increases the volatility in the stock
but these guys are being penalized
because they're losing money the people
who sell at low points and then buy at
high points and increase the volatility
they're getting killed they're you know
they're falling every day so it's not
like you have to create some penalty for
those guys their penalty is that they're
just bad traders they're bad investors
and they're just going to lose their
shirts so if you're assuming that none
of these traders in any way manipulating
the markets or spreading false rumors
anyone making market anyone making money
in a on a stock as long as they're not
manipulating it on either the short or
the long side is actually a net asset
for the stock that they're actually
reducing the volatility of the stock
price I guess another thing to think
about and this is just from a you know
it's good they're reducing the
volatility so from that point shorting
doesn't seem too bad for me or in
general to the market but another way to
think about it is kind of where all the
incentives in the markets right who has
an incentive to be positive on a stock
and who has an incentive to be a
negative on the stock or to scrutinize a
stock scrutinize screw scrutinize
alright there you go well you know the
biggest I guess cheerleaders for a stock
and it depends on their degree of kind
of credibility or or ethics would be the
company's management right these are
people whoops my pen let me undo that
it'd be companies management these are
people who obviously run the company but
they have the best transparency into the
financials of a company and they tend to
be shareholders of the company or get
compensated based on how the stock does
so these guys have every incentive to be
positive and as we seen multiple
examples of whether you're talking about
the investment banks or Enron or
Accenture they'll often kind of hide the
truth when things get bad so these guys
are definitely I mean big-time positive
on on stocks and then let's see who are
the other play
are the influencers in financial markets
well a big one is the financial press
and I'll write it out here so we can
have a discussion about whether they are
pumpers of stock or whether they tend to
be more whether they tend to scrutinize
things a little bit more an important
thing to think about with the financial
press and I you know next time you watch
CNBC and I don't want to just pick pick
on them is you know how do they make
money right do they make money by
finding things that are wrong with
companies do they make money by making
you money or they make money by selling
ads they make money by selling ads and
then the next question obviously is were
they selling ads to is it is it are they
selling ads for mops are they selling
ads for bicycles no they're selling ads
for they're selling ads to to financial
services companies to financial services
companies financial services so people
who want to manage your wealth
stockbrokers mutual fund companies
anyone who can advertise and this is key
to because I don't know you're probably
not aware of it but hedge funds can't
advertise so they're not they're not
consumers of the financial or they're
not customers of the financial press the
only people who are customers of the
financial press or money managers you
know financial planners and things like
that brokers brokers mutual funds and
all of these guys benefit when stock
markets go up obviously mutual fund
managers will will you know they tend to
be long only so they only want things to
go up stock brokers you might say oh
well you know a stock broker can can
advise you to go long or short and they
just care about how many transactions
you make but in general more and more
people put money into the stock market
in rising markets in a market like
you're seeing right now over the last
year people are pulling out pulling in
you know you could say oh maybe people
are doing more transactions but the
general net effect is people are pulling
money out of the markets so when they're
pulling money out of the markets they're
you know brokers are getting less
transactions are managing less money and
that's also true of the money managers
and there's also just a you know another
ancillary side effect is when market
go down and people become less excited
about the stock market people stop
watching CNBC and you know cnnfn so and
and so even those few ads that are for
mops and for bicycles and for cars will
get fewer viewers so in general the
financial press at least in in my
opinion is squarely in this camp
financial press and then we can talk
more you know sell side analysts you've
probably heard the term sell side and by
side but sell side analysts are the
analysts that work for the major
brokerages and investment banks who
publish those reports that you you see
in those ratings of by rating on IBM or
whatever and the reason why they call
them sell side analysts is because they
work for the people who are sell
essentially on some level selling you
could either view them as their they
often offer securities or they offer
financial services to often the
companies themselves or to potential
acquirers of the companies or there
they're selling their services I mean
usually or their brokerage services so
they're trying to get people to transact
they're actually brokers on some level
but clearly these guys their incentive
since their customers tends to be the
management of companies is to be very
very very positive and then usually say
oh well you know there are other people
who would their whole job is to
scrutinize these people like the
government but if you think about it
once again the government likes a rising
stock market it takes you know when
people's 401ks are rising it you know
the economy does better the government
doesn't have to worry as much about
social you know other types of social
benefits and unemployment and things
like that so in general and and if you
want to be more I guess if you want to
be more critical of the government you
could also say that there to some degree
they're very close to the management of
these firms and to financial companies
and to some degree these guys have
significant clout in terms of lobbyists
and well actually I would even say the
bankers to their significant clout in
terms of lobbying and and just an access
to government generally and you know
government drives the regulator's so
these guys are also on the positive camp
and then finally have the ratings
agencies and the ratings agencies mainly
operate in the debt world and we'll talk
more about that but if you can
scrutinize a company on the debt level
and you say oh wow you know this company
really isn't that good they're not going
to be able to pay off its debt that
kills the stock right but once again you
have to realize that the rating agencies
are also paid by the bankers so the
rating agencies are also have the
incentive to kind of not see things when
things are bad so out of every one of
the financial services or the financial
world that we've talked about right now
they all benefit when stocks continue to
go up even when they go up beyond what
they really should go up and even if
they all kind of know that things are a
little bit too expensive or this
management team might be a little shady
or they might be covering up something
none of these people really have an
incentive to expose it and the only
people who do are the short sellers
these are the only people who really
have you know arguably the
sophistication and the time and the
monetary incentive to really look and
scrutinize what management is doing to
really look in the books and kind of put
a pup you know put a put a puzzle
together or put a bunch of pieces
together to come to a conclusion wait
you know the numbers the management is
pouting really don't add up and because
of XY and Z this company really is
overvalued so on to a large degree they
are kind of on on Society side in
preventing management from kind of being
overly bullish and I don't want to sound
like someone who just broadly is
defending short sellers there is a class
of short sellers that I think would be
bad and that's the people who are
spreading false rumors and being market
manipulators so there's this a general
you know market manipulation
manipulation market manipulation or you
know rumor mongering and that definitely
is bad and to some degree if you can
show someone is doing that there should
be some type of penalty for doing it but
even there you know just in my
experience participating in public
markets if I had to pick you know if I
had to pick between the left side of
that chart between this side of this
chart and this side of this chart and if
I had to say who does who does spread
false information
when it does get spread I think
oftentimes management is a little bit
more guilty of it than the short sellers
in fact there's very few times that I've
seen where the short sellers are you
know there's some negative thesis on the
stock and where it really comes out to
be completely untrue although you know
there are examples and those short
sellers you know I don't think are are
really in the mainstream anyway I don't
want to meander too much I realize that
this video has already gotten long but I
thought it's a it's a nice useful
discussion to maybe think a little bit
about whether short selling really is
all that bad even if you are a long
investor